good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toes and happy [__]
Friday [__] okay happy [__] Friday
[__] okay h ffb o k k happy Friday lard
happy Friday fle we are on the same
planet today both wearing cozy outfits
and Ugg shoes and hats and Today's
Energy is definitely giving slob energy
which is perfect because one of today's
SP on of sex.com and a lot of people
have noticed how our copy for sax.com
calls us out calls us out for like being
slobs and you know what sorry we're so
on brand today and we're so in line with
our with our brand values and we were
just trying to make the copy true today
because we do have a sax ad today and we
just we don't want them to look untrue
by the way when you said sax just now I
thought you were going to say s asra I
wish I could say sag asra I was singing
a song this morning and like now it was
pretty girl rock it was like um why were
you singing Pretty Girl Rock I don't
know it was just in my head it's a good
song don't get me wrong but I was maybe
one of the lyrics was like after and I'm
just like
after sag Afra goodbye goodbye goodbye
you were bigger than the whole
Sky you were more than just a star short
time I've got a lot to Pine about I've
got a lot to live without I'm never
going to meet what could have been would
have been what should have
been that's beautiful Jack I never
realized how much I would miss it I
think we did actually yesterday we
talked about it at
length but I'm I like it's I'm still
human like it's just because we said
goodbye like doesn't mean it's over it's
over like I don't think of it as the end
think of it as a new beginning don't cry
because it's over smile smile because it
happened smile because people were out
of work smile because the strikers got
what they
[Music]
wanted if you're not watching on YouTube
you're So Many you're watching on
YouTube you're missing a big
smile oh today is just giving like
Delirious energy day I did have like two
cocktails last night so I'm not feeling
like number one you know for sure but I
just want to say no don't cry because
it's over smile because they they got
some of the points they were looking for
I saw friend dresser on
um what is Billy Bush on these days he
was interviewing her like the bush uh
Entertainment Tonight maybe you would so
he was like I want to know like which
a-lists have reached out to you like no
I think he wanted he just said I wanted
to know what celebs reached out to you
and Fran was like you know I actually
heard from a lot of my a-listers I'm
like oh okay they're your a-listers and
she said George Clooney was like I would
have bet my house that you couldn't have
gotten us the deal that you got
something like that apparently Fran
crushed it okay apparently the deal is
good yeah like something about a billion
dollar okay yeah I I'm not 100% sure on
the details but that's pretty much in
line with us talking about
sag but also in line with sag talking
about sag like literally they announced
the resolution yesterday and the memo
like did not have the deal points right
it's giving sag it's giving
sag um we've got a great show today like
a
really Next Level I you always come in
early in the show and say like what kind
of show we have and I just feel like
it's presumptuous because like we don't
know what kind of show we have until the
show is done but I would say given our
record we have a record of having a
great show Nothing in life is guaranteed
you're so right ja but here are the
reasons why we can theorize that Today
Show would be great hypothesize
hypothesize one Jackson cloud or
original recipe in the the studio New
York City two it's Friday always a good
energy yes three we're wearing hats I
think I'll wear this hat to the party
tonight and so I feel like we're going
to be just different in our hats and the
hats have kind of become just kind of
like a subplot of the toast yeah yeah
like who's wearing a hat which hat are
they wearing will they take it off in
the middle of the show where is Mr
hat did he ever call snitch no no
and another reason what band was Mr Hat
a part of the Lost Kings yes not a band
a DJ Duo yeah another reason why the
show would be good if I may presume pres
further further is the stories are good
good which is rare for a Friday yeah
they're good good yeah there's one story
that I think will spark the most
dialogue out of all the stories but you
never know which one are you thinking
not any that you know of not any that
were discussed prior oh yeah she's got a
she got something up sleeve just there's
one story that opens it Up For Debate
tangents those are the best types of
stories yeah IMO not really debate
that's a little misleading cuz it's not
like about takes it's about
predictions I have chills I have chills
let's talk more about the show that
we're not getting into yet but that we
want to talk about well let's talk about
how this is our last show of the week
and it's also the last show of you being
here in New York cuz you're obviously
head at home this weekend and what a
delight it's been wrap up your trip for
me maybe give me give me three words to
describe your trip short
sweet
fun wow such good words I mean like what
do you want me to say lifechanging
incredible to reference or not reference
give birth to it throw it up put it in a
blender bus Club another club bus no
we're having a nice time it's been
really fun it was a nice like short trip
but also kind of a good length
and it's been a pleasure you know people
have a like a lot of problems with how
you and I say
length length yeah like apparently
you're not supposed to pronounce the G
length
length no
length length length like l a y n t h
lengthy Wilson length length length if
there wasn't meant to be a g pronounce
they wouldn't have put it in
100% 100% any other problems people have
with us oh forehead
forehead where let me where do I begin
you know yeah yeah oh don't forget my in
K yeah
asking tellink tellink starlink I for so
long I didn't know what people were
saying when they said that like I was
like this does not compute I don't know
what you're telling me I'm doing now I I
understand okay I can take
responsibility for my actions so what
you're saying is that you're listening
I'm listening I will not be doing better
I will not be learning I will not be
changing my ways because this is how I
am and you need to be more accepting and
more tolerant of me wow she really
flipped the scrape on that one yeah whoa
the tables have turned except people's
[Laughter]
differences you know what today's
episode
title
you know how like in certain or like
like you spit on someone Jackie
culture
actually what I said Jackie's
culture that wouldn't be good
transcribed no no no it's more of like
an oral presentation it's an a
experience a experience it's an Audia
experience Claudia Claudia Zia title
great for a podcast title actually there
was a man named claudo his podcast
should be called Claudio's audio audio
with
claudo yeah the thing is I don't think
there's a man named
claudo unless you transition or and go
by CL I thought you were gonna say give
birth no and I would give my son for
sure claudo claudo or you could
transition I could but I don't think
that would be my name oh what would it
be like Maverick yes
[Laughter]
deceased um
so you think it's
time okay I no but like we didn't even
do what we usually do in the beginning
of the show yet which is what like how
are you how's your night you went out oh
yeah I did I hit the town I saw some
friends I ate dinner I had a delicious
meal like me and Ben wheeled ourselves
out of there you know like that it was
that kind of meal you know it's a good
meal if Claudia is posting the food to
her stories that we went to saki noan
which is just such a good sushi spot and
one thing that's so criminally
underrated about sushi spots is their
dessert like you know that little
chocolate cake they always serve with
like a little green tea ice cream I
don't [__] with the green tea ice cream
oh I like the green tea ice cream I
don't like love a chocolate cake no I do
it was like a souly and it was like that
does not it for me liquidy in the middle
does not do it for me the whole thing
the like green tea Mochi does it for me
so we got like a bunch of desserts and
the chocolate cake was in front of me
and like everybody was like trying all
the different things and I was like this
one's like not so good and I ate the
whole thing so that nobody else could
eat it and then when it was over I said
now that it's over I just want you all
to know like this was the best thing
here but I bogarted it for myself that's
so dirty that's so dirty it's the
dessert she will steal it's so T it's so
deliciously for
me by the way
Grammy for that song Grammy to whoever
put that poop together where are they
now I can't imagine it's
good because Talent like true Talent it
doesn't get seen appreciated in its own
time yeah I feel like I definitely was
doing my part in appreciating that song
while it was on air but even now years
later like I can acknowledge it's still
slops yeah what did you do last night
well I was with you oh and then I hung
out with Dana and then snitch came over
I didn't know that and it was a last
minute
snitch stopping by and it was lovely be
a dinner together we chatted it was
actually really nice that is lovely yeah
and then like attempting to put Charlie
down for hours until he finally
acquiesced that's so Charlie yeah it's
actually like not he was having some
sort of gas last night which he never
has but it was okay we figured it out
just figured not to like you know tell a
mother what to do when I'm clearly know
nothing but did you try the Tik Tok
thing the bicycle no like a variation of
that which I saw you know uh years ago
when I but like both legs up just like
pushing them up not like bicycle no they
do bicycle for first and then you pull
back and push mostly I just like push
both a little to the side a little to
the side I wish somebody would do that
to me yeah just like stretching and it
was good it was good yeah good so we
figured it out I don't know like what I
ate that why was this milk different
from all other all milks yeah maybe you
were poisoned by you I had lunch at your
house you did have lunch at my house but
we ordered it I had a great day
yesterday I mean Harry like went to the
park it was just mommy COA mommy COA
says like that's why you're wearing that
hat today it says Mama mhm M I'm
literally like appropriating Mom culture
you are but it's fine well I was telling
you actually I've been doing that a lot
recently yesterday at my friends Margo
bris I was um talking to like a bunch of
my friends who are moms they were
talking about just like Mom life things
and like nannies and things like that
and I was like no I we're experiencing
the same thing now it's been really
really tough and they were like really
I'm like yeah no and I keep saying we
like we're like a surrogate family we
are we're a unit is what we are we are a
unit I'm sure they were like girl get
the [__] out of here I don't know I feel
like you have a lot of information I do
and that's the thing like knowledge is
power so it doesn't really matter where
it's coming from as long as I'm being
educated as long as education is
Paramount right which it always is not
always not always some people put other
things ahead of Education like their
agendas 100% I hate to see it chilling
chilling chilling stuff okay I am ready
I'm ready too so without further adoo
here are the fast five stories that you
need to know and the fast five stories
that you need to know are brought to you
by State Farm the State Farm personal
price plan helps you create an
affordable price just for you the plan's
all about being personal to you and your
needs that means you're getting the
coverage you want a policy that helps
cover what's important to you and an
affordable price just for you because
after all life is just better when you
can personalize your experiences so
think about it like this from your go-to
coffee order to your favorite pair of
sweatpants we know that you love to
personalize your entire day just like we
do I mean what's more personal than
coffee like not me spending a whole year
just to find out like the this the one
from the grocery store you know even our
morning routines Jackie was sitting here
having a breakfast taco I was having a
Bita like we're so different it's so
personal and St F gets that and what's
more imp personal than Insurance cuz
that's your life and life is personal I
feel like you just exposed me on the
breakfast taco I don't feel like people
would associate me with having a
breakfast taco okay Jackie has two
breakfast tacos literally every time
she's in New York before we start the
show they're many So when you say two
like they're they're small
no you guys they're enormous they're the
biggest things I've ever seen in my life
I started eating them like when I was
pregnant cuz like but the way this is
not about you no offense it's about
State Farm so if I can continue but
you're the one who put my breakfast on
blast what I was saying is that
personalization just makes everything
that much better and State Farm believes
Insurance should work the same way your
plan your coverage your selections can
all be personalized by you so like a
good neighbor State Farm is there prices
vary by state options selected by
customer availability and eligibility
may vary like a good neighbor State Farm
is there do you one like a good neighbor
State Farm is there today's episode is
also brought to you
by like a good neighbor sa f is there sa
f is
there say safe arm is there safe arm is
there you guys these tacos are so small
today's episode is also brought to you
by sax.com we are always doing our best
when it comes to looking fabulous on the
it's so
hard but it's so hard for two slobs like
us we love sex.com because sometimes our
pajama uniforms and our sweatshirts
Shady shade at copy.com need a bit of an
upgrade and that's why we love shopping
at sax.com for everything from podcast
looks to gno outfits to everything in
between and it's actually true we do
shop at sex.com don't let today's
outfits be a reflection of that no can I
just tell you I get targeted ads from
saxs and they literally have not like
the most me things ever like I was just
saying how this gift that I sent to
Margo to get me like it was the fendy
baby carrier like they not only have
wide range of products they also have
such great like gift ideas such niece
gorgeous items it's also super fun and
easy to shop on sax.com whether you're
going for a cozy Vibe a more elevated
look they've got it all at sax.com and
at sax.com you can even shop by your
star sign or by your situation so you
can find the perfect Revenge dress from
Brands like esber cult Gia holiday
season being a sax mates it so easy they
have great customer service great
shipping easy returns so it's perfect
for the holiday season obviously
shopping and store is so fun the saxs
here is like the place to be during the
holiday season I can't wait for their
decorations and windows to go up but
doing um their shopping online is so
easy so discover new ways to shop for
everything every day whether you've got
a business conference going on vacation
you could really select on the website
and find just the items that you're
looking for you can find new ways to
shop for everything every day at saxs
at sax.com today's episode is also
brought to you by Bow and Branch this
year give yourself a better night's
sleep with the softest most luxurious
sheets from bowl and Branch this single
upgrade will immediately change your
sleep and bring you the dreamiest Bing
experience their signature sheets feel
breathable luxuriously soft and they
even get softer with every wash the best
part is that you can try their sheets
for 30 nights to make sure that they're
right for you so um the quality of Bolam
branch is unmatched I've had bam Branch
for years I think betting is something
I'm truly an expert on and can be deeply
trusted on love Boling Branch my home
for the past several years has had
bowling Branch Jackie's bedroom Jackie's
home that includes my bedroom over there
is also bowling Branch it if it ain't
B&B I don't want it bowling Branch
products are made different you can
sleep better at night because they're
made from the rarest 100% organic cotton
on Earth they're free from toxins
pesticides and harsh chemicals at every
step of the making and they're made by
Artisans who earn the pay and respect
that they deserved the signature hem
sheet she collection which is what we
both have it comes in a ton of different
colors sizes varieties they give you a
30- night worry-free guarantee with free
shipping and Returns on all orders so
upgrade your sleep with 25% off your
first order at Bow and Branch that's
their best offer of the entire year so
just head to Bow and branch.com use
promo code toast t o St take advantage
it's that time of year now and B and
Branch this is their best and biggest
sale like this is something you need to
just like do band Branch b o l a n d
branch.com promo Cod toast it's a
limited time only exclusions apply so
see the site for details that site is
Bowlen branch.com and our promo code is
toast thank you la you're welcome fa our
first story is some Big Marketing news
that's Making Waves Patrick and Britney
mahomes's two kids show up their silly
sides in an adorable holiday campaign
photo shoot for skims pajamas by Kim
Kardashian so this is Making Waves
because Patrick Mahomes Kansas City
Chief's quarterback and his wife Britney
Mahomes are very close to one Taylor
Swift and Travis Kelce and now they are
the faces of Kim Kardashians pajama
Christmas campaign yeah so this would
have made waves like even if Britney
hadn't become so close with Taylor
because like her holiday campaigns are
always like very it's like it's Buzzy
regardless talk about the men's you know
they always have like the by the way I'm
so glad you just brought that up I was
watching football because the Jets
played the Chargers and they lost like
100 to one do you know that there is a
man on the San Diego Chargers who is
Nick Bose's brother it's another set of
Brothers oh no San Diego Chargers wait
no they're La Chargers now w yeah and
they're both in California cuz he's on
the 49ers Nick Bosa oh wow so I wonder
if they live together so I saw him and
I'm like Ben oh my God Nick Bosa got
traded he was like no he has a brother
he's a brother brother cute maybe they
could be like the next Kelsey right if
they play their cards right and their
game right if they play their game right
good luck I would love to know all of
the brethren in the NFL I'm sure they're
not the only ones no I know there's
Brothers in the NBA um Mark and Pal
Gasol
it makes sense though because
genetically if you're going to be really
tall oh yeah but also like if you're in
a house that like prioritizes Athletics
and you have athletic jeans like it's
really not that crazy yeah I agree
Brothers in the NFL by the NFL okay
first one is Jason and Travis Kelce wait
they're Brothers next um Shaquille
Griffin and shaem Griffin so cute they
were both on the Seahawks that's cute I
like that Devon mccordi and Jason
mccordi mordia mordia mordio there's
there's 29 slides in this slideshow oh
JJ Watt Derek Watt and TJ watt oh
there's three there's three they don't
get enough Shine for that well JJ watt's
not in the NFL anymore I feel like he is
okay but he's not so that's cool he's he
is there's 29 slides oh Payton man
Manning Eli Manning oh that was a good
one you know they milk that one like
they did but they've also like defied
being Brothers cuz I didn't even think
of them it's so true cuz they really are
both uniqu talented and they're both
quarterbacks which is crazy and they
both like won Super Bowls and Eli didn't
Eli might have won yes Dan gronowski
Chris gronowski Rob gronowski oh those
other brothers play too oh what Chris
was undrafted but he played for the
Cowboys coltson Broncos oh okay like the
draft is overrated even though it's the
best day of the year um cool Trifecta
I'll back to Britney Mahomes so this
would have been Buzzy no matter what but
obviously the timing is pernicious to
say the least
and what does pricious mean not what
like
nefarious okay no I didn't suspicious I
didn't mean aaras sure suspicious is a
better word um now I have to imagine
like like any billion dooll company Kim
and sks's holiday campaign is shot
probably in February so I think it's
possible that she wasn't friends with
but they also do turn stuff around so
quickly that's their thing is like
getting the people who are Buzzy you
know Megan Fox and Courtney they're
walking down the street one day and then
a week later they're in a skims campaign
so I feel like it wasn't February like
most holiday campaigns but there's a
chance that it was like pre-boxed with
Taylor yeah no it's a good
question
because not that Britney let's say let's
say Kim reached out after box with
Taylor not that Britney should have said
no because like and I think Taylor would
say like an opportunity is an
opportunity you know she respects the
hustle of being a businesswoman but it
would be weird yeah do you think there's
a chance that like Taylor and Kim are
cool that they've like buried the
hatchet privately and they're not going
to be like you know running around
besties but that not everything is as
heated as it feels it's possible I do
know the last time Kim was asked about
it was on watch wein live yeah and she
was like Watch What Happens Live LA no
in New York oh she Andy was like Taylor
Swift and she's like over it of course
she's over it right that's the thing
it's not a question of whether or not
like Kim can move past it it's a
question of I don't know I I don't it's
like not a it's like so big in Taylor's
life you know what I mean I agree it's
her Roman Empire yeah I just wonder if
like she's able to maybe um like just
place all the blame on Kanye at this
point and forgive Kim even though like
Kim posted the video video and Kim like
started the snake thing yeah no there's
no way no there's no way Kay would for
her mov no but there are so many
especially lately like so many weird
overlaps I mean Taylor going to Simon
Hook's birthday party that's Kim
Kardashian's best friend I don't think
she knew I think she just happened to be
like her friends were invited and she's
like yeah I'll go like yeah but you
don't think like Taylor if they're in
the Uber like thinking where to go like
Taylor's not like vetting where her
friends are taking her I think she no I
think of her friends like Gigi and Cara
like they know her forever they they're
not going to ever put her in a spot
that's like bad I I I don't think the
that Simon's thing like meant anything
in terms of Taylor and Kim
no but there have just been so many
overlaps I mean that's it's Hollywood's
a small town Tinsel Town no and Kendall
Jenner is like the thread holding it all
together she's the Lynch pin because
like gig's best friends like she is like
she has like a best
friend in fashion and then a best friend
in like the rest of the world and that's
Taylor and Kendall yeah so it's got to
be weird for
her
yeah but I thought the shoot was really
cute I like Britney Mahomes I'm like
here for the Redemption era of Britney
Mahomes people are show me to her for no
reason
mhm was that it leave Britney Alone Oh
it sounded like it was in the middle of
a sentence no oh yeah no really cute
holiday campaign um sweet family hope
like it's all good with Taylor we'll
know soon if they're back at it I don't
think Taylor would give a [__] and I
also don't
think if it was filmed before Taylor
can't say can't be mad about anything it
was filmed after I believe Britney would
have told and asked ask permission yeah
like she's not stupid yeah or just like
you know run it by her cuz she's a grown
adult she doesn't need permission no but
I'm sure she doesn't want to upset her
new friend yeah and she would give it up
if Taylor was like don't do that but I'm
sure also like Taylor has to be cool cuz
it's like as much as like her
boyfriend's friend yeah it's like she
can't be running around telling her
boyfriend's friend like what to do with
his life and his business like oh you
can't be in this person's you know what
I mean like she can't come off like so
controlling and crazy also it's
important to know like just based on
like outside perception of how I'm like
viewing Taylor's life this is probably
the happiest she's ever been it's
definitely the most successful she's
ever been um and when you're in other
things felt by the wayside after that
wait when you're in that sort
of peak nothing like you don't get
dragged down by like Petty moronic
[__] yeah like this like I actually
don't think Taylor cares at all yeah
zero% but even if she does care I think
she's going to keep that to herself cuz
she doesn't want like her boyfriend's
best friend to think she's crazy like
look small you know look small when
she's like your breakfast taco it was so
small you guys like it really was by the
way no they are like small tacos they're
manyi tacos it's not like that's why you
just went you said two it's you just
need to clarify yeah but you did have to
not today and not yesterday that's what
we keep saying they ran out oh yeah you
were did you did say yesterday and today
there was only one left at the place
both days oh my God are you hungry cuz
it was so little and you only had one no
because one is small but two is kind of
too much so now it's like oh I could go
for a treat after this so yeah
is there anything like fatter than me
like it was really small no like in
defense of your own consumption yeah no
no I had two tacos but they're really
we've all been there yeah our next story
more tailored news but about our girl
Kelly Clarkson who said that Taylor
Swift sends her flowers after every
re-recording release so Kelly knows all
too well how sweet Taylor is the
Superstar revealed to e that Taylor
sends her gifts after every album
releases she said you know what's so
funny she just sent me flowers she's so
nice she did she was like every time I
release something cuz she just did 1989
I got that really cute cardigan too oh
Clarkson also maintained that Taylor
would have come up with the idea of her
re-recordings on her own despite Kelly
taking to Twitter back in 2019 amid the
battle with scooter to make the
suggestion that tweet like in in the
midst of all in the midst of like this
crazy situation Kelly Clarkson like
tweeting like the sweetest most innocent
tweet tweet at Taylor Swift just a
thought you should go in and re-record
all the songs that you don't own the
Masters on exactly how you did them but
put brand new art and some kind of
incentive so fans will no longer buy the
old versions no it's so sweet that's
exactly what Taylor did and I'm sure it
wasn't like the most unique or original
thought and I like I actually really
appreciate that Kelly said that like she
would have done that anyway but like the
fact that she acknowledges my tweet this
is like the best story ever yeah it's so
cute it is really cute and also so funny
how like not thirsty Kelly Clarkson is
like Taylor's been re-recording for 2
years now and we're just now find
finding out that like Taylor
acknowledged Kelly's tweet yeah like I
think if anybody else got a gift or a
set of flowers from Taylor's f it would
be on Instagram in 30 seconds yeah but
Kelly no she runs it like you can't
really impress Kelly but do you think
like Taylor knows that anyone who she
says flowers to I'm sure there's a note
like she just assumes that they'll like
post it so do you think for the last two
years she's been like getting my flowers
Kelly why the [__] when you post this
I'm doing this nice thing maybe but I
actually think like Taylor and Kelly see
each other you know
it's like me and you yeah you're the
tailor to my
Kelly okay next year's Halloween that
would be so Random insane so dumb so
dumb so Niche we would just be reciting
the Tweet back and forth Taylor should
go on her show though I was thinking
that too because that's obviously it's a
big platform but it's also like now like
a safe good option for tailored yeah but
Kelly hasn't gone to
an eras tour she's a busy woman she is
but also there was like a little drama
with Kelly and Taylor like two weeks ago
did you see what Kelly was just like
complaining that like oh she wants to
watch football yeah and that like
football has become all about like
Taylor and Travis but then but then she
released the statement she was like I
wasn't saying anything about the people
I'm just saying I want to watch football
yeah which I think is the sentiment of a
lot of people yeah and she put out a
statement that she was not here for this
narrative maybe that's why the flowers
thing is coming out now to like men
fences
I just know what's in Kelly's heart and
I know that it's a pure it's pure of
heart it was pure of heart she's black
of hair and pure of heart yeah her hair
is always changing that's what we love
about Kelly yeah remember when she did
the Skrillex that was
psychotic but one thing about Kelly is
like she's extremely unpredictable you
never know what's going to come out of
that mouth it's so true it's so true I
love her I love them collab I love us
I'm so glad you brought that up I love
us are you ready for our next story got
to get your thoughts on this number
three number three don't worry you're
safe I've been marked as safe Travis
Barker roast his being roasted for
playing the drums in the delivery room
when Courtney Kardashian was in labor
you haven't seen this no he posted this
video of himself playing the drums in
the delivery room he was drumming along
to the heartbeat of his unborn child as
Courtney was delivering his baby he said
practicing to my baby's heartbeat drum
Emoji fans immediately took to the new
dad's comment section to troll him with
several claiming his drum playing is a
major ick someone said that wouldn't be
annoying at all well the thing is is
that there's only one
person who can declare this as either a
good thing or a bad thing and that's
Courtney Kardashian whose vagina was
about to be ripped open by a baby and it
appears as though I don't I can't
imagine he did this without her approval
or her desire yeah so I have to assume
that she wanted it and so that's nice
then it just you know obviously you put
yourself in
the question like how would you feel if
that were you if there was a drum in
your ear I mean I've never given birth
you
speak but keep in mind it's like the
greatest drummer of all time who is um
providing a soundtrack to an important
moment in your life and he's using the
baby's audio as baby's heartbeat as
audio inspiration There's Something
Beautiful about it but is drums the type
of instrument that can be enjoyed
solo yes okay in the right context okay
in the right context um so for me I like
peace and quiet I don't even want anyone
to speak to me unless like they
absolutely have to tell me you know
what's going on it's medically a
medically necessary bit of speech um so
for me I would pass right for Courtney
though I'm sure she found this to be
beautiful endearing yeah spiritual
bringing the heartbeat to life maybe
also
encouraging maybe helping her in her
pushing you say bring the heartbeat to
life that's actually beautiful that's
really beautiful so I'll say that yeah I
mean different shes for different folks
that's also true but no it it could not
have been me it will not be me
imagine Ben Sofer bringing a set of
drums oh my God into a New York City
hospital room which is literally like uh
12 s f feet to it's one drum he brought
his like travel little drum look there
he goes there he goes That's just in my
opinion like a good way to get killed
cuz I will kill you
yeah and those sticks can be used as
Weapons P I'm in pain and you're playing
the drums yeah
death but I could see her being into it
especially maybe she even like I don't
know if she would do a natural birth I
feel like she would like do a water home
birth but she didn't she's in the
hospital but she had complications right
right but um and also I think she would
have done that maybe in her earlier
pregnancies but after like a certain age
like she just wants to be in the
hospital yeah yeah yeah but I wonder if
she ever did natural with her natural
being unmedicated with her other
children and if she I'm sure she'll tell
us about the birth this time and if she
did natural because when you do natural
you need kind of like crazy things like
this to to put help push through did you
watch any birthing videos before I've
I've given birth twice I've still never
seen a birth I've given birth zero times
and I've seen like three you're obsessed
I'm not one of them I saw against my
will I like met someone once and she was
like you want to see it I was like oh
okay it was like a home water birth it
was one of the craziest things I've ever
seen in my life and then I watched
Brian's birthday video that one was nice
yeah I just I don't feel the need yeah
no I don't think I would watch one ever
again yeah like I've seen enough yeah
it's cool
like I'm good you're so good like I like
my PO my experience better of birth
better than like you know just seeing
it I think it's unnecessary I think you
either are the birther or you're the
partner is z watch yeah yeah if you
don't have to experience it you have to
watch it yeah yeah yeah but um he wanted
to watch if he had not wanted to I would
have been totally fine with I didn't
like ask him to or anything um but that
made him I think have more of an
appreciation for what I was doing right
more respect more respect put some
respect on my name is that the story you
thought was going to like nope oh wow
we're not even there yet we're not even
there yet but are you ready for the next
story no okay get ready so we got a
brand new sponsor a very exciting one
Sunglass Hut it's the season of giving
but finding that perfect gift can often
feel like searching for a needle in a
hay stack but we have found the solution
to all of our gifting woses at all the
shades of holiday at Sunglass Hut where
it's about the magic of gifting so if
you're like us there's always that one
person on your list who's impossible to
get gifts for but we have the solution
for you no matter what they're into
you're bound to find something memorable
thanks to their holiday selection that
includes styles from the biggest brands
like Prada Doling gabana Versace rayan
Oakley Burberry their wide range of
sunglasses cover some of the hottest
Brands plus their curated holiday
collection includes 10 Shades only
available at Sunglass Hut I went to the
flagship Sunglass Hut in New York City
on fth Avenue a couple days ago I got
four pairs of sunglasses I got you two
pairs cuz I'm a nice sister um let me
tell you what a fabulous experience you
four yeah oh I got two okay let me
explain math to you I got four two for
you okay you guys that was confusing was
it no I think we all understood okay but
let me tell comments let me tell you I
had the best time they shipped directly
to you I in store they're like it's 3 to
5 days they're so they're probably going
to be waiting for you at your house when
you get home Wendy my sales associate
was amazing she was like helping me like
figure out my face shape cuz my face
shape has changed and like the glasses
the glasses I would normally flock to
like the oversized ones she's like those
don't work for you true so true what's
your face shape now I don't know what my
face shape is but she says I really like
have a good face for a square top round
bottom H yeah so it's just really
helpful to like learn things and also
Sunglass Hut just has amazing I was
telling her I'm like why am I always
shopping at Sunglass Hut at the airport
and she's like cuz you're always going
somewhere fabulous and you need a new
pair of sunglasses Wy she understands
you like no other no she was Fab and you
know during the holiday they do
engraving and they can service your
products if anything breaks like it's
really um it's such an underrated
activity shopping for sunglasses oh it's
so fun so head over to Sunglass Hut
discover the special selection of Shades
in store and online at sunglasshut.com
there's the perfect gift for everyone
this holiday so head over to the nearest
store or go to sunglass hut.com and
check out their unique selection of
Shades that are only available at
Sunglass Hut you're going to find what
you love visit them in store or online
today's episode is also brought to you
by seed all right girly swirlies it's
gut Mania you know G everyone's obsessed
with gut health the IND is loud
everybody's posting about it on
Instagram and that's where seed comes
in sorry I'm like my paperwork is you're
just like I'm like a paperwor but no we
do love seed and we've been talking
about seed for a while here at the toast
and one of our favorite things about
seed in addition to all the other
benefits is the BSD benefit the big soft
Duty benefit so the ds01 daily symbiotic
is a plant-based Prebiotic and probiotic
with 24 strain that have been clinically
or scientifically studied for its
benefits so if you wanted to start
taking a Prebiotic IO and a probiotic I
think seed is the best place to start
for a multitude of reasons one being
that it's free from 14 classes of
allergens that are defined by the efsa
so it's sugar-free it's vegan it's soy
free Sesame free gluten- free peanut
free ampa free dairy free shellfish free
corn corn free it has no binders no
preservatives and the best part is that
it's engineered to survive so if you've
taken a probiotic or a Prebiotic and
felt like it didn't do anything it's
probably because that didn't survive
your digestive track but seeds is
engineered to survive your external
internal environments they're capsule
and capsule via cap safeguards viability
through digestion for delivery for
delivery of an average of 100% of the
probiotic starting dose to your colon
the outer capsule also serves as an
elegant barrier why take a probiotic or
a Prebiotic BSD big soft Duty lots of
skin benefits your gut health your heart
health lots of benefits with the DS1
daily symbiotic from seed so cut through
the gut health noise visit seed.com
toast and use code toast to redeem 30%
off your first month of seeds DS1 daily
symbiotic that's seed.com toast use code
toast thank you la you're welcome fa our
next story is so upsetting oh God is
this the story no not the one of of
discussion and now we've overhyped it oh
[__] okay but our upsetting fourth story
is that Ki Kiki Palmer has accused her
ex Darius Jackson of domestic violence
she has filed for a restraining order
and custody of their son so the two of
them share eight-month-old son leotus
and now Kiki is requesting Soul custody
for her eight-month-old son I think they
call him Leo um who she shares with
Darius Jackson after the child's father
has been physically abusive on multiple
occasions she filed the request in La
according to documents reviewed by
people in the California Superior Court
filing she alleges that on Sunday quote
Darius trespassed into my home without
my knowledge or consent threatened me
then physically attacked me lunging for
my neck striking me throwing me over the
couch and stealing my phone when I told
him I was going to call the police she
also includes screenshots of what
appears to be security footage of a man
striking a woman over a sofa she uh she
alleged is that he has abused her
multiple times over a 2-year period
another incident was allegedly recorded
on home security footage from February
2022 when darus body slammed me onto the
stairs by my neck in the Declaration she
alleges there were quote many instances
of physical violence including striking
and grabbing me around the neck
descriptions of darus destroying my
personal property including Diaries and
prescription eyeglasses throwing my
belongings into the street throwing my
car keys to prevent me from driving away
hitting me in front of our son spewing
profanities about me to our son
threatening to kill himself with a gun
if I left him harassment and other
physical and emotional abuse oh my God
I'm literally going to cry literally
going to cry there's there's more in the
filing too and more details and
instances um and then also to put it
into context their issues briefly went
public in July when he called her out
for wearing a fitted black bodysuit
under a Shar dress to watch Usher's
residency that was such a [__] weird
psychotic thing to do it like the fact
that all of this was under the surface
it makes complete sense me of like an
iceberg where it's like that was the tip
of the iceberg and then when you look
under the water it's like this huge
Mound but all you see is that like small
thing I'm sick you want to know why for
a multitude of reasons one because Kiki
pommer is a person who like radiates Joy
yeah and to know for the last two years
while she's been making everyone laugh
on her podcast and just killing it
everywhere and we're always talking
about her that she was experiencing this
like that makes me so mad and so sad two
it's always a [__] loser a no job ass
hat [__] face [__] with a success like
it's always that you know get a [__]
job you [__] loser oh my God I'm so
angry like Kiki pommer is my queen like
I'm so mad so mad I hope she gets full
custody I hope she never has to see this
piece of [__] ever again jail and then
there's like jail for the abuse yeah no
good on her it's clear that she kept a
record that's what they say like you
have to do if you're in an abusive
relationship and like you actually want
like just saying like leaving and being
like my husband is or boyfriend is you
know violent and not having any sort of
record of that like there's nothing the
police can do so it's clear like that
she kept a log she has security cameras
like and she's so lucky to have that
because so many people don't have that
and they can't like prove it and get a
restraining order yeah oh my God I'm
sick I'm sick I hope I see that man with
my car
yeah no I hope I'm in my car and I see
him and you know what I wouldn't even
know that I saw him because he's such an
irrelevant [__] jobless loser it's if
Darius Jackson came over and spit in my
mouth I wouldn't even know who he was
that's how irrelevant and unemployable
you are you [__] seriously I just pray
that everything goes her way if it's a
swift case and she can get this loser
out of her life get custody [__] you oh
my God I'm so mad so mad by the way if
you are experiencing domestic violence
call the National Domestic Violence
Hotline at 1
18007997233 or go to thehotline.org all
calls are calls are toll-free and
confidential and the hotline is
available 24/7 in more than 170
languages you guys please yeah you know
I ended up on a side of Tik Tok where
people were sharing um like them finally
getting out of their domestic violence
situations like it was like literally
making me cry like cuz you just I think
when you're in it you think like there's
no possibility my life could be anything
other than what it is right now and then
like years later you know they meet men
who are good and they have babies and
like it's just I I like loved seeing
that
um and I remember actually it's so funny
what sticks with you like from your
childhood things you learn when I was in
high school we had like a like a speaker
come and talk to the girls about
domestic violence and it was the first
time I ever heard that like you know
leaving obviously we all have free will
but like most of the time you actually
can't leave cuz when you're young you're
like well if somebody does something bad
you leave like question mark you know
it's not it's not really a question and
like how Financial abuse is a thing and
then like even in Kiki story like taking
your car keys like physically not being
able to leave and it was so impactful
and it was just like a random day in
high school and I remember being like
why are we doing this we're literally 13
and I really remember everything she
said yeah like it was one of those like
health class PSA things that really
stuck with me that's great yeah she was
a good speaker great well thank you well
at least this story has given
us a way to remind people that it
doesn't have to be that way and it
shouldn't be that way no and putting
your hands on you was so [__]
unacceptable yeah are you ready for our
fifth and final story that has been um
long oh it's been okay now I'm like so
curious an Elon Musk bio is in the works
at a24 with Darren aronowski set to
direct and questions as to who will star
as Elon so here are the details in Elon
Musk biopic is in development by the way
I want to say I know who it's going to
be we'll talk and variety has tapped
Daron aronowski variety has confirmed
that Darren aronowski is on board to
direct Walter isaacson's authorized
biography of the tech Mogul so that's
the bio of Elon that's out right now and
I think Elon contributed to it but it's
not um you know it's by it's not by Elon
um it was published in September and it
will serve as the basis for the
screenplay he also wrote the book Steve
Job which was previously turned into the
2015 film starring Michael Fender which
I feel like didn't wasn't good I didn't
see it I didn't see it but like I don't
there was also that time where there was
like four jobs movies ker was allive
jobs and I feel like they were all bad
yeah um so
now the question is who shall play I
know I have a really really good call
okay Ramy Malik so there's another
Variety article of like who of who
should play him and he is one of the
choices by the way I just want to say I
came up with that all on my own I didn't
even know that this I didn't know about
this book I didn't know about this movie
I just thought of it myself that's a
really good guess thank you I think he
would be really good also Nicholas Cage
is um question mark if you look at them
next to each other they kind of look
alike oh my not Ramy mik like being in
the headline oh my God that was such a
good call it's Nicholas Cage Elon Musk
Ramy mik I don't see but also what
what's life stage are we right like do
we get young Elon old Elon or are we
going to age Elon I think we age Elon I
think we go with someone in their 30s
yeah and then you can always look older
but you really can't look younger but
you know with CGI you could get in your
20s who else are people suggesting um
Jesse Eisenberg all right but he did
Mark Zuckerberg right yeah wasn't he in
yep Robert Downey
Jr question mark what someone suggested
uh Brendan
Frasier okay I love Brendan Frasier more
than anyone in this world like are you
you guys BL like Brendon faser is like
60 years old Matt LeBlanc from Friends
also love he's 60 years old here's a
good one John
Ham well that would be very generous
yeah that would be generous oh or an
AI generated version of him um no um the
internet
[Music]
all what it should be played by Kathy
Bates
look at they do kind of look
alike that's funny that's funny um okay
who should play May musk me no no Helen
mirin yeah oh there's an old lady Helen
mirin who should play
Grimes Sophie Turner oh that's really
good yeah yes Sophie Turner and Bren and
frager who should play Amber herd Amber
herd oh who should play Amber herd
that's the problem with like making
movies about something that happened
yesterday it's like why can't Amber herd
play Amber herd that's actually such a
great question I don't think she'll
actually be in the biopic but I do think
the biopic will be interesting because
like we all forget like Elon Musk we
know him as like he's always Making
Waves you know the Thai uh submarine
thing like the dickipedia the dickipedia
he's always being like funny and
whatever Twitter and he's kind of like
like a prankster like yeah but we we do
as a generation and myself included like
we forget he's the also the Einstein
like what he has done and that's why
when I watched his Netflix documentary
um about
SpaceX I was floored no he I was like I
can't believe more people aren't talking
about how we made a fully recyclable
rocket ship like it was insane he is the
genius of Our Generation he is our
Einstein but he also is the silly goofy
guy he's also like our steo from Jackass
like get you a guy who can do both right
but he gets more attention for the
pranking things I literally forget about
like SpaceX about Tesla and I would love
to know what he did before he did PayPal
right he what he did before all the
things that because now he's famous but
before he was just like maybe 10 years
ago he was just like a famous rich
person so I'm sure there's so much we
don't know about him and honestly like a
biopic is is necessary and I would love
I'm glad also you know on the one hand I
don't like things that are that don't
have time to age but on the other hand
like we'll get elon's thoughts on his
biopic hysterical and you know he'll
share them with you you know he will and
you know they're not going to all be
good positive he's going to go in but
can we talk about a24 for a second sure
I feel like a24 has never made a good
movie does anybody else feel that way
let's see what they've made it's this
like Buzzy production company they did
that Pete Davidson horror movie like
they're always doing like random [__]
but they they did just do the Priscilla
movie which I feel like was more
elevated for them oh and they did uncut
gems which feels to me like the exactly
what you're saying of like movies that
get buz sound good and Buzzy and like I
didn't see it so I can't say it wasn't
good but I just feel like it wasn't yeah
ladybird I didn't like but I'm alone
actually I didn't I didn't I liked
ladybird but I just didn't like it just
because of like the story it just wasn't
for me like they didn't do a bad job
with it it just wasn't for me exmachina
oh my god did anybody see that movie
wait I'm in the middle of saying
something you have to see that movie no
it will [__] you up then I'm not going
to see it why would you say that I
should see it it's honestly like a Black
Mirror episode and then like Spring
Breakers yeah you know what I mean like
a24 has this great reputation I think
they have this reputation cuz another
movie they did was Moonlight and
everything everywhere all at once and so
those are the sorts of movies that then
you can make movies forever yeah no
that's true and with the if they just
did one of those things with the new
Priscilla one it's not out yet but I do
think that'll be good for them too yeah
but sometimes like you say like blank is
making a movie and you know it's going
to be good and I feel like a24 people
act like that oh it's an a24 movie and
it's really um like not guaranteed they
also act that way about Darren aronowski
yeah now is he the one what did he do
was he with Jennifer Lawrence yeah
Jennifer Lawrence but also he just did
the whale no I know him as a director I
mean like scandalized why oh was he was
that the director also that um Lily
James or Kristen Stewart was with
remember like the the Huntsman one yeah
I don't think it's Kristen Stewart let's
Google that was like it was a long time
ago Kristen Stewart director Huntsman
aair I don't know for sure if it was the
Huntsman um you you don't no snow I
didn't have I feel like it was like
Twilight honestly rert Sanders oh okay
so that was someone else when she was
spotted with like the married but wasn't
Lily James also spotted with the married
director or was that uh what's his face
and not Dominic West but it was like in
the same era where Lily James was kind
of like [__] [__] up just cuz she
felt like it rubert Sanders was the
Kristen Stewart one confirmed confirmed
R now let me see what happens when I
Google
him H I'll just Google Lily James Affair
director domic West oh that was Dominic
West so it was just Dominic West okay no
no other one okay but Darren aronowski
is at the Jennifer Lawrence Affair not
Affair but he's like her director oh oh
oh oh I'm sorry okay maybe I'm just like
conflating that Christen Stewart thing
with like something else I think so okay
okay I didn't mean to Slender the great
Jennifer Lawrence you know they're just
like you know partners in crime right
they did ma Mother Mother Ma being like
Donna something else yeah they've like
they're Partners maybe she's kind of
like a muse I think yeah for sure but
not anymore or else maybe she'll be
playing Amber herd by the way great call
love that for her love that okay what
other movies did he do I feel like we're
always searching this Darren aronowski
yeah Black Swan that's the sort of thing
that will buy you Goodwill in Hollywood
Forever Forever whale mother Noah the
wrestler The Fountain not familiar
yeah um so this is Fab I will totally
see this movie same just honestly I'm
interested in learning about like what
like Elon outside of like an internet
user cuz you forget there's a there's a
great there don't forget
SNL right I think I'll read this book I
want to know what Elon thinks about this
book is this like an Elon approved
sanctioned like does is he like hey
that's a that's an accurate picture of
me when you tweet him and ask it's the
only way to get in contact with him it's
so true or like I'm sure he's spoken
about this book that's been written
about him just like let me know what
Elon thinks about the book so that I
don't have to go and find out for myself
I guess I could Google it yeah I'm sure
I'm sure there's something there there
yeah I'm sure there's easier ways to
find out than like waiting for someone
to tell me what are we thinking for
today's episode title oh it was in the
beginning that we said it okay no no no
no this happens every
day audio with you know how I feel about
putting our names in the title's very
against it we do it once in a while when
like it's but like T every day could be
like tur's this tur's that it's just
like it's too inside baseball I agree I
agree we're trying to like always gain
new listeners and we want like people to
see the title and be like that's funny
right and click it right and I think
when it's just too inside they don't I
agree but I know that in the beginning
of the show things were said that would
have made for a good title small
tacos you and I are twoo small tacos
twoo small tacos I like that that's
funny because I like it well that's our
last show of the week on Monday Jax will
be back in Florida so we'll be doing our
remote setup but it's been such a
delight to have you here it has been
lovely just like two girls in hats in
New York two girls and hats who are
small to
two girls in small hats eating small
tacos in a small studio in New York
City that's the title that's the title
thank you guys so much for listening to
the to Morning Show where we the St
every Mond Friday YouTube watching on
YouTube
THS a beautiful standing and wly
talented we are have a great day guys
love you bye love you
bye